he is a director of some of our all-time
great famous fun movies that's why as
part of our poll question LBJ in
theaters near you released last Friday
starring Woody Harrelson as the
President of the United States shortly
after the Kennedy assassination and
prior to the passage of the landmark
Civil Rights Act in 1964 the director of
that film Rob Reiner good to see you
rich thank you for having me thank you
for coming here on my play before we get
into the movies let's talk some sports
okay look I guess I know you're a Dodger
fan I'm a big Dodger fan what do you
think of that World Series well I I
thought was a great World Series up
until the last game and I was one of
those as the game started I was why is
Yu Darvish starting this game I mean he
had been so bad in the game before I
understand you know you give a guy
another chance he's been in tough
situations before but if Clayton Kershaw
was willing to pitch four or five
innings which is what he did ultimately
right you have to start him then so we
have to start your best pitcher if
because they're never thinking that you
Darvish is gonna give you more than four
or five innings it's not like you did
that that Dave Roberts just thinking I'm
gonna get seven innings out of you
Darvish so if you're thinking I'm gonna
get four or five and you know you've got
Kenley Jansen for at least two Morrow
for one I'm starting my best pitcher see
the moment that I thought that because
it yeah it's it would have been tough to
basically say okay our game five
starters now our game seven starter
certainly after what Kershaw looked like
in Game five with a four and three run
lead I know so that that's an
interesting you know supposition
certainly based on what we saw what he'd
looked like in those four I understand
but you know sitting there in only the
right there at Dodger Stadium was Sandy
Koufax who did pitch the seventh game
after having pitched the fifth game yeah
and there used to be a time when you
could have you all you needed was two
pitchers two starting pitchers because
you can do you can have one two day off
day off and then start them again you
know and win the four games and I don't
you know I understand
fresh arms you know you only go 100
pitches and all this stuff but I asked
Raleigh fingers about this one time and
I said
what is the deal about a hundred pitches
and he said I don't understand it
because they throw 50 pitches in the
bullpen before they're getting into the
game to warm up they're throwing eight
pitches between innings and then the
hundred pitches so you're already throw
you know if you're gonna go seven
innings you're already throwing two
hundred pitcher what's the difference
you throw two hundred or two hundred and
twenty pitches I mean it's just doesn't
make sense than with you to rob because
you know the analytics world that we
live in right now yeah that it seems
that so many managers are into the
perfect example is and then I don't Dave
Roberts manager of the Year last year
listen he did a great job he's gonna be
this year in the National League yes so
he did a great job the finalists for the
National League Manager the era or
managers are the two teams that finished
behind the Dodgers right right you know
West right so I wanted to put that you
have eight out there none of us before
you know I'd say Dave Dave Roberts has
been great all year and there is to me
there should be a balance between
sabermetrics and gut yeah he's got to
find that you know in between thing and
for the most part I think Dave Roberts
does because in Game two they took rich
Hill out of Game two after the four
innings because when he goes through the
lineup for a third time his numbers
based on ethics right so the odd as well
take him out right there but to me that
just drives me not because there's it
but what have they done the analytics on
take on a guy in a World Series game
after four innings because they don't
have Rich Hill for that and there's a
little bit of an extra thing that's
pumping through your system and that's
the gut part of it that I don't think
they factored in yeah we had Rob Reiner
here on the Richard show we had AJ Hinch
on yesterday's program yeah and I asked
him about that game two in the ALCS why
he kept Verlander and against the
Yankees a hundred hundred and ten
hundred pitches is so rare that we saw
yeah we see you know you had mentioned
Koufax I just I throw out the name Jack
Morris like that sort of Jack Morris
yeah right just that that guy is just
knit or the the twinsies is never gonna
come out of a big World Series game or
the ALCS and he said that you do have to
just find a difference between the gut
and knowing what they what they can do
and you looking at your
absolutely you got to find the balance
because there is a thing called a gamer
and I you know I know Kershaw struggled
you know and some of the championship
series of the seventh inning was the big
Bugaboo inning and all that's right but
I got to say the guy is a gamer and he's
a tougher competitor than anybody on
that team I would go with him always go
with him so now I got mad at Dusty Baker
for putting in for not putting in Rob
nen for two innings in a game against
the Angels I mean you got a go with the
guy that you're gonna get you that thing
and you gotta ask a guy to get 6 outs
you'll get you 6 a nice 2002 World
Series yeah that you're referring to out
there yeah this is so you're you're
dying I like baseball
I love bass what about football what
about the end I like football except I
don't like that the the head injuries I
worry about that's what I worry about I
mean I'm a big New York Giants fan and
now I gotta be a now I gotta I guess I'm
in LA I was an le reste and when they
were here the first time you know with
with Deacon Jones and you know rosey
Grier we had an all that great team and
I had season tickets then but then they
went away and so when you I guess let's
just start unpacking in the pop culture
part of this conversation so when you're
shooting all in the family you're going
you've got you've got season tickets to
see the Rams yeah Roman Gabriel and you
know they had you know okay and growing
out a grown up here well that was when I
was a teenager okay no older but I'm
when a growing up as a kid I was a New
York giant fan okay I loved you know you
know it would here's how funny I went to
school with with Kyle rotes son so Kyle
rote jr. you went to yeah yeah I was the
school them and so I asked him I said
who's your favorite football player he
said my uncle Tobin cuz Chopin wrote was
it you know a quarterback you know and
Kyle was you know Kyle was a receiver
and a half package but I love Kyle wrote
I loved you know you know why a tittle
and right John I know all the great
pleasure he just we had rosy Brown too
and rosey Grier we had yeah we had the
two Rosie's on our team is there have
you ever cast some of us an athlete
that's the great actor in any of your
you know I have to think about that I'm
sure I have you know
nothing off the top here I can't think
off the top right Andre the Giant well
there you go
how about him what was that like Andre
was a coolest guy man I mean he was the
sweetest guy in the world I mean
literally the the cliched gentle giant
and he was that guy and very smart he
told me that he grew up in the town in
France where Beckett Samuel Beckett was
in that town used to walk to school then
my guy who wrote Waiting for Godot and
Andre the Giant walking to school
together he took him to school so what
was there any doubt that when you're
looking for that character in Princess
Bride that Andre the Giant was the guy
well bill Goldman said you got a cast
Andre he said you gotta be in me know
first first of all it's not like you
throw a stick and you hit 50 Giants I
mean you know you got it it's not a heck
of a lot to choose but he said Andres I
said GZ be green Oh obviously Andre and
we had to we had to find him because
he's you know traveling all over the
world we're calling Vince McMahon trying
to get and finally we get to we just
come back from scouting the cliffs of
insanity you know in Ireland The Cliffs
of Moher we come back to hotel they said
you can meet Andre in Paris tomorrow we
go right back to the airport we fly to
Paris we stay at this hotel and then we
you know mess around from the day I go
back to the hotel and the guy at the
desk says there's a man waiting for you
at the bar we walk into the bar and
there's a landmass sitting on a barstool
and it was Andre you know and the rest
was history yeah yeah he auditioned for
me and I didn't understand a word he I
didn't understand a word he said I was a
three-page scene and I I didn't
understand it I said and and I said you
know Andre this is like a big part you
know it's you're gonna be like here for
like 15 weeks he says dude boss dude I
know you do it I mean but I don't know
so I made a tape and I sent him the tape
and he you know he listened to the tape
and he did it I mean I didn't have to
loop it or anything
and well when we come back I want to ask
you our poll question which we've been
asking for the three hours this favorite
favorite Rob Reiner film okay of which
obviously Princess Bride is one and
we'll talk LBJ and some more okay that's
next in 60 seconds more with Rob Reiner
at Rob Reiner on Twitter here on the
Rich Eisen show we're back in 60 seconds
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show LBJ
in theaters near you starring Woody
Harrelson as LBJ Rob Reiner directed
that film here on the Rich Eisen show
let's get into that film right now why
why LBJ why now why'd you get involved
you know it's a great question because I
was of draft age you know during the
Vietnam War so I I hated him I mean he
was on my enemy you know I was against
the war and he could send me to my death
so I was against him but I've spent a
lot of time in politics as I grew up and
I worked on public policy I actually had
a job here in California California
government for seven years and I got to
understand what he was able to
accomplish on a domestic level second to
FDR probably no president has had the
greater accomplishments than than LBJ
and I thought this is really a tale of
two presidencies you you know except for
the Vietnam War he would have gone down
as one of the great American presidents
of all time but you can't separate it he
had the Vietnam War so I wanted to know
who is this guy who is he and that's why
I made the film I wanted to get into his
personnel and how did Woody Harrelson
come across well it's amazing because
when people ask me you know who plays
LBJ I said Woody Harrelson they said get
out of here no no no no he gave me I
said where do you see it where do you
see what he does in this film and I
picked him because not only from Texas
and you know he has a good sense of
humor which LBJ did he also has the
humanity that I wanted to get across
that you think of LBJ's like an arm
twisting bull in the china shop you'll
you know do whatever he takes to get you
to you know do his will but he also had
a very very insecure sensitive side that
I discovered and reading a book by Doris
Kearns Goodwin so I wanted to get that
in there and woody brings all that to it
so what my gosh I'll just ask you a
macro question I'm going to ask anything
well is your show real thanks Rob
because we talked about you know Dave
Robertson
imagine having to go with your gut and
also knowing what you what you like and
is there a similarity to directing with
all the different yeah types of
personality yes yes there are a lot of
different personalities and the one
thing that you have to do in any kind of
managerial position is you have a lot of
people they all have different skills
and you want to encourage them to do as
as good as they can to be perfect but
know full well that if they're doing
perfectly what they're supposed to do
it's knocking somebody else out of whack
and they need to work all together so
you get them described for perfection
and accept you know something less that
they can be okay with and that way
everything gels together so if you have
one ego sticking out too hard it doesn't
serve the the overall it's like that
with a film with a team or anything a TV
show as well as yeah yeah yeah ask Rob
Reiner our poll question for the for the
day that we've been asking on our app
Apple App Store and Google Play and the
link at the top of our Twitter handle
that Rich Eisen show okay guys what's
your favorite Rob Reiner movie spinal
tap Stand By Me The Princess Bride When
Harry Met Sally a few good men which one
would you choose those are the choices
you have those are the choices now have
you been polling people already where
you want to get we have so the Princess
Bride is currently at 38% right late
surge by a few good men right 31% right
stand by me 15 spinal tap 9 When Harry
Met Sally 8 okay interesting well you
know like like you love all your
children of course so no matter what
they are you love them equally that's
not true
it isn't true why do you have children
that's not easy no but I'll tell you
what I have like baseball gloves and
shoes and like I have favorite pairs of
those why wouldn't it be the same for
kids well you may be a great point every
one of your kids is a giant screw oh
yeah and you don't like him as much as
the one that's most successful well you
make a great point I mean it shows a
real understanding of the human
condition that's my role it's hollow
inside yeah
yeah so well for me and it's not
necessarily what I think is the best of
all the films but for me the one that
means the most is stand by me because it
was the first time I made a movie that I
felt reflected my personality my sense
of this so what what was that about well
it's a mixture of there's humor and
there's some melancholy to it and it was
I was 12 years old in 1959 which is when
we said it and so I have a feeling and a
connection to to it and what the little
boy Gordy is going through in the film
did you have with Stephen King involved
and very much he wasn't involved
although I got to say one of the great
experiences I ever had was first showing
the film to him and we showed it to him
privately I was there and two of the
three of the other producer we were all
there and I was so nervous because he's
watching this film and I knew it was
personal story for him because he
actually lived that I mean he went with
his three buddies to see this dead body
and actually three of the three buddies
that he was with they all passed away in
the book and that's what happened to the
boy and in real life and in the film we
only had the one die cuz I didn't feel
it was believable to have everybody that
anyway we watched he watches the film
and we finished and then he says I just
want to think about this for a little
bit I'm gonna I'll come back in about 15
minutes I'm thinking oh god oh god I
hope he likes this he comes back and he
says well I just have to tell you this
is the best adaptation of anything I've
ever written
he says that's not saying much but now
he made a joke but he said this I love
this film so much and he said and in the
book it's Chris Chris picks up the gun
to to fend off the older boys and we had
Gordie do and he says when you had
Gordie pick up that gun I saw I thought
why didn't I think of that
no Kay yeah and so that was the coolest
and then we got to make seven other six
or seven other Stephen King movies
because he then would give us we
optioned his books for a dollar he said
you know I trust that you'll be able to
you know do what are you most proud of
on that misery with the well misery we
did
Shawshank Redemption which to me was how
did that not get on well I didn't I
didn't I didn't I didn't director
directed film no bar company produced it
and we did Dolores Claiborne and needful
things but the point is we had a good
relationship with Steve okay sure yeah
and I mean for him to say that I mean
the shawnee is out Carrie Bennett yeah
yeah that was it was really really cool
Rob Rana here on the Rich Eisen show and
a few good men
casting Jack Nicholson in that role and
watching him do his thing we've had
we've had Kevin Bacon Noah Wyle on this
show talk about that the the big scene
obviously yes you can't handle the truth
right well and we've heard it from their
perspective of watching an actor and
you're an actor and director what was
that like from your perspective well it
was interesting because you know we have
a big courtroom and you know jack has
this long long monologue and I said to
him before I said look I'll give you a
choice
either I can shoot if you want to shoot
ready now I'll shoot you right now if
you want some time to work on it
rehearse it I will shoot all the
reaction shots first and then we turn
the camera around on you and you know
whatever he said why don't you you know
shoot the reaction shots and that will
get me to it so you know I got Tom
Cruise cutaway to me more Kevin Bacon
the you know it got you know Kevin
Pollak I mean you know though judge the
jury I'm doing all the reaction shots
and every time he's off-camera he gives
exactly the same performance that you
see that's on camera after two or three
I said I go when I said Jack you know
maybe yeah you want to save a little
because I mean he's full out and
everyone and he's off-camera and he says
Rob you don't understand I love to act
he says I don't get that much of a
chance to do a great part and then we
turned the camera around on him and it
was the same the same nailed it he yeah
every time where did where did you where
did spinal tap come from that came from
why did I I produced and acted and did I
wrote it with my buddies Chris guest and
Harry
shiron my we wrote a TV show which was a
satire of different things on television
cult TV show we did sitcoms we did
telethons we did commercials we did
everything was a guy flipping around
from one little thing to one of the
things we did a take-off was a thing
called it was midnight special was a
late-night rock and roll show which was
a real thing and was the first time we
had spy I would play Wolfman Jack who
does the show half face it baby to hit a
Wolfman you know I did that guy and I
introduced spinal tap the were England's
loudest band and we had spinal tap on
for the first time and they did it and
we did a thing called rock and roll my
mirror and they started improvising in
the characters and then time went by and
we said wait a man do something more
with these characters so we came back
together and started working on how much
of it was ad libs it's all the whole
thing is improvised there's only one
speech that was actually written Patrick
McNeil says tap into America hmm he
wasn't an improvisational actress so we
wrote a little speech for him but the
rest of the thing was completely
improving to 11 turning everything and
my favorite thing about that is Elon
Musk you know who created the Tesla you
know when he first had the Tesla he came
to there was a party and I saw I said
what's this car he says this might a new
car that I'm gonna start putting out
there called the Tesla I said wow it's
really cool car he says let me show you
something he sits me down and
passenger's seat and he says look at the
volume and the volume went up to 11 he
says I love the movie I put the vibe and
the air conditioning goes up to 11 - on
a Tesla if you get it you look at the
Tesla that's what happened so I was a
big guy so when you did the line did you
do the line and then then create
something - yeah that's the yeah yeah
yeah well we know we were gonna make you
know amps that go up to 11 you know and
he said that and I said and I said well
why don't you make 10 the top I mean we
just improvising and it's the last thing
for you to I could talk to you all day
Rob Rob Ronnie here on the show what was
it like growing up around Mel Brooks
well it's a lot funnier than growing up
around Artie Raven you know I mean you
know I mean there was funniness in my
house
you know Mel and my father and Sid
Caesar and Aaron Reuben and Norman Lear
I mean there were the funny sirs like
you would just there were funny people
in the house yes but I get all you think
it's normal because you don't know
you're a kid you figure that's that's
what it is and then when I went over to
my friend Mike leads this house I
realize not so funny over here not as
funny as over there unbelievable
I mean I could just pick your brain and
we didn't even obviously talk about all
in the family but but then if you keep
picking I don't have much less true I
need it for other things
understood yeah for your next film yeah
LBJ check it out in theaters near you
Rob Rana directed Woody Harrelson
starring in it Richard Jenkins who I
love also he's terrific great he was
great at Six Feet Under
he's a great that's a great what I call
a none sweaty actor okay one of these
guys that doesn't push anything
everything's real and it's just so
natural awesome Congrats on LBJ and
thank you come back any time wrong
alright thanks for having me got at Rob
Reiner on Twitter for more Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app